I was traveling around these island
communities in the north of the country
where people are dealing with a river
erosion and flooding every year this is
a picture of the men of a community in
the north of Bangladesh moving the local
mosque and this is an example of a
simple adaptation that people are made
to face the challenges of a changing
environment if your village is dealing
with seasonal flooding and shifting land
masses will you start to build your
buildings in a way that they're easily
transportable so this mosque was under
the threat of falling into the river
because of the ocean so one afternoon
the men of the community decide well
it's time to move it to higher ground so
they dismantled the mosque after the
morning prayer they all get together
they actually carry the whole roof to a
higher ground and reassemble the mosque
and the whole operation I was amazed to
know more than 78 hours